what did she say to him
i don't know
[Music]
hello and welcome to the no nonsense
beauty quiz with me elle turner
glamour's deputy beauty editor and emma
bresky
activist influencer and skincare rookie
yeah we're going to ask each other a few
questions and see if we know the answers
bring it ready yes let's go so question
number one
what does hyaluronic acid do a
exfoliate b hydrate
c reduce pause or d
brighten that one always kind of
intimidates me a bit because
like it's an acid so i don't know i want
to say
exfoliate to be fair the word acid
throws a lot of people off because it
sounds kind of scrubby
but it's actually best for hydrating
it's natural in your skin so you have it
in your skin already
and it is the best ingredient that you
can get for plumping and hydrating skin
i have a question for you when it comes
to serums what should i be looking for
so your serum is basically a lighter
more
potent version of your moisturizer which
means it's going to sink into skin
more deeply like a shield exactly so the
one that i would recommend you go for
is antioxidants they help to protect
your skin so they're perfect
for in the morning and they'll help to
neutralize pollution ultramoon is a
really good example of this
it's like an invisible shield for your
skin okay
and it has some antioxidant heavy
weights in there like reishi mushroom
iris fruit extract and if you feel it
it's got a really nice
silky texture and then the other serum
that i would really recommend
that's best for the evening is retinol
which is a form of vitamin a
speaking of retinol true or false
can retinol help reduce the appearance
of acne
i want to say true because i feel like
retinol dries out spots doesn't it yeah
acne is one of the things that can help
with it's a total multitasker so
it's going to help to decongest your
skin and there's two things that i would
say
you should look out for one whether it's
paired with a nice
soothing ingredient like rose hip oil
and that's gonna make it feel much more
mild on your skin
so this has rose hip oil in it actually
if you try that on and then the other
thing that you should look out for
is whether it's encapsulated and that
basically means that the retinol is
buffered within
a more mild gentle ingredient as it goes
through your skin it's also the gold
standard in skin smoothing because it
can boost
collagen okay and collagen is what you
need for really fresh
plump looking skin natural filler
natural filler exactly so it can help
smooth out any little fine lines
nice skin looking really fresh so
personally
i'm more of a less is more type
thing you know so i was just wondering
what would you say are the three
must-haves
in like any skin care routine number one
is a decent cleanser because not only do
you want to make sure that your skin is
nice and clean
because if you have anything left over
like a little residue it can build up
and it can build up it can cause
congestion which causes spots
but it can also create a barrier between
your serum and your skin
so then there's like no point in having
a serum
the second thing is something to hydrate
if you've got
quite oily skin and it's the summer for
instance
you might find that your serum does the
job on its own if you've got
quite dry skin you might need something
a bit richer and then
number three is spf always even in the
winter
because you're not just wanting to
protect your skin from uvb which causes
burning
you also want to protect your skin from
uva which is in the atmosphere
year round it penetrates deeper into
skin and it can cause
longer lasting damage so next question
what do you think this does um
well straight off the bat i want to say
it's a brush
you got that one right yeah it's so soft
super duper like a pillow yep it's for
foundation
yep you're right so the rules with this
are there are no rules
yeah this one in particular like you
said it's great for the face it's nice
and big and fluffy
it's got this little dimple in the
center which you can apply your fluid
foundation it makes it look like a
hot crust a little hot crust bun and
then you can use it to apply it all over
your
face just buff it in with these really
soft bristles so it's really good for
blusher bronzer and contour so a bit of
everything
what is the best way to apply skin
products
so i would say take a generous dollop of
your moisturizer
dot it onto your cheeks your forehead
your chin
your nose and then take your ring finger
and your middle finger
okay because these are the lightest
touch and then apply in
upward motions so you can go along the
contours of your face your jaw bone
underneath your cheekbone
and then up on your forehead as well
yeah and that's just going to give you a
little extra bit of lift
nice naturally natural lift feels good
too
so that is everything that is our
no-nonsense beauty quiz i hope you
learned some things
so much i mean from rookie to expert
within minutes so thanks so much
mission accomplished